During the '90s and early 2000s, it seemed
like Edward Norton was pretty much everywhere.
He took roles in a wide range of classic movies,
including Fight Club, American History X,
Kingdom of Heaven, Red Dragon and The Illusionist,
and was beloved by fans almost as much as
he was lauded by critics.
In recent years, however, it feels like he's
almost entirely disappeared from mainstream
Hollywood.
Here’s why.
Leading the trail
Despite his hasty retreat from the acting
spotlight, Norton has kept himself busy on
the production side of the film industry.
Since 2015, he's been listed as a producer
on Lewis & Clark, a long-awaited HBO miniseries
about the two famous explorers who trekked
through the Louisiana Purchase at the dawn
of the 19th century.
“It’s taken a long time getting it all
together but we finally ready and we're starting
to shoot it this summer”
Unfortunately, filming on Lewis & Clark shut
down after only two months.
Thanks to an array of further production issues,
the series still has no release date.
Calling the shots
In over 20 years in Hollywood, Norton has
only directed one movie: Keeping the Faith,
a 2000 rom-com about a Catholic priest and
a rabbi fighting over the woman they both
love.
Norton has recently returned to the director’s
chair, however, with Motherless Brooklyn,
a 50s crime drama adapted from the novel of
the same name.
Perhaps unsurprisingly, Motherless Brooklyn
has been the subject of some controversy.
A fire on location destroyed an apartment
in March 2018, leading to a lawsuit against
Norton’s production company for “recklessness,
carelessness and negligence.”
The same blaze also claimed the life of firefighter
Michael Davidson, whose family subsequently
issued a wrongful death lawsuit against the
company.
Working behind the scenes
One of Norton's more recent roles came thanks
to Seth Rogen's animated movie Sausage Party,
in which Norton voiced Sammy Bagel Jr. an
anthropomorphised bagel who sounds suspiciously
like Woody Allen.
Both the character and his familiar-sounding
voice was Norton's idea.
“Can we all just calm calm down a notch,
try to be amicable, I'm Sammy Bagel Jr.
I'm happy to meet all of you.”
Rogen told Deadline,
"He really latched onto it, and was a huge
proponent of it, and said from the very beginning
that he wanted to play a bagel that sounded
like Woody Allen.”
Norton was also instrumental in getting Sausage
Party made in the first place, encouraging
Rogen and his collaborator Evan Goldberg to
stick it out when the going got tough and
convincing other big stars to voice characters
in the movie including Kristen Wiig and Salma
Hayek.
A major bomb
Norton's most recent major role came in 2016’s
Collateral Beauty.
Despite a stellar cast and some pre-release
Oscar buzz, however, the movie flopped hard
at the box office, earning a measly $31 million
in the U.S. largely because it shared a release
date with Rogue One.
Critics panned the movie too, and Collateral
Beauty ended up failing to provide the comeback
vehicle for Norton that it so easily could
have been.
Family focus
Though he's usually pretty cagey about publicly
discussing his personal life, Norton has opened
up to the Independent about his decision to
ease up on acting.
He cited his personal and family life as a
reason for this, highlighting the need to
strike a balance between acting and what he
called:
"[...] other things that are really compelling
or interesting or challenging to a different
part of your brain or your personality."
The conversation soon turned to Norton’s
view of the film industry as a whole.
He said:
"I just think that I'm less interested than
I used to be in, like, exploring genre for
the sake of it.”
He went on to explain that he prefers to take
roles in movies which are innovative or unique,
or are helmed by particular filmmakers he
respects such as Spike Lee or Wes Anderson.
Doesn’t quite explain Sausage Party, though.
Roasting Marvel
In 2018, Norton made a rare televised appearance
as a guest at the Comedy Central Roast of
Bruce Willis.
Naturally, Norton made some harsh jabs towards
his Moonrise Kingdom co-star.
But much of Norton's routine appeared to simply
be a set-up to attack Norton’s true nemesis:
Marvel, saying,
"I did a big action movie called The Incredible
Hulk.
[...] I thought we should try to make one
Marvel movie that was as good as the worst
Chris Nolan movie, but what the hell was I
thinking?"